[Music]
in the united kingdom pies are king
not just for the cherries and the apples
that you yanks are used to you have your
chicken your steak and kidney your pork
pie
and in one tiny fishing town you have
this
a pie with
what wait is it is that fish head
oh you've gotta be kidding me
trust me you're gonna love it
in this tiny fishing village there's a
pub and in that pub they make stargazey
pie
it's a tradition that legend has it has
been happening here for hundreds of
years which begs the question why the
starry gazy pie is a pie which
celebrates tombow cox going out and
catching seven different kinds of fish
on the 23rd of december
you see according to the legend it had
been a stormy winter this meant no boat
managed to go out of the fish so people
were starving but a local fisherman tom
bocox he wasn't going to let his people
die i'm going he went out through the
gate yes that gate and braved the storm
and
and caught the different kinds of fish
and brought it back he made the pie
and that brings us to today tracy take
it away you get six different white fish
bake that in the oven with some herbs
and some lemon zest put a layer of
grated eggs a nice mashed potato with
loads of cream in and then you put a
pastry lid put pilchards cut them and
then you put so that the heads are
coming out the pie and the tails are
coming out the pie you assemble all the
stars around the pie
on the 23rd of december we give it away
free to thousands of people that come to
the village to celebrate tom pocock's
night so to tom bocox what a legend
cheers tom
so should we taste it
that is good
delicious that really is quite delicious
it's good
really good
the fish is lovely it's most interesting
it's it's much milder than i thought
fishbone
[Music]
welcome to rochester new york the home
of kodak eastman situated on lake
ontario and creator of the finest
delicacy in all the land hey can i have
a play with all the garbage on it please
that my friends is the garbage plate and
let me tell you
it is glorious
my name is alex tahu my grandfather
invented the original garbage plate
called hots and potatoes and my father
perfected the real garbage plate at this
point you're probably wondering what
this so-called garbage plate is i'll
tell you a garbage plate is
let me handle this
garbage plate starts with your choice of
sides from home fries french fries
macaroni salad or beans
and you pick your meat hot dogs
hamburgers cheeseburgers whatever's on
the menu then you add your toppings from
mustard onions and hot sauce ketchup and
red hot is optional then add two pieces
of italian bread and butter and you're
all set to go over the years we've had a
lot of different kind of garbage plates
we actually had our sardine plate years
ago i don't think it could get much
crazier than sardines
[Music]
the best part of this business is of
course the customers without them would
be nothing the place was established to
give people a lot of food at a
reasonable price
for years people have come in here
hungry that didn't have any money my
father always fed them that's really
sweet alex but let's get back to the
garbage because i'm really wondering how
many calories are in a plate i really
don't know some people have said three
thousand i don't think it's that high
but i guess i'd have to be a
nutritionist to tell you
but i will say this is the only place
you can get a garbage plate any other
plate in rochester is a copycat we
trademarked it so now it's world famous
trademarking garbage genius
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
three words you should never ask what's
in
haggis lom's liver lum hearts lom langs
well too late now let's do the
[Music]
story this is frasier mcgregor he's a
haggis maker i'm a champion hunter's
maker ah he's a champion haggis maker
here in dingwall scotland at cockburn
george and sun and they don't hide their
title we're the first jumping huggers
makers in scotland we won the title in
1976.
chances are you've never heard of haggis
or at least you've never tried haggis
and that's because it's a very very
scottish dish hargis has been around for
centuries in scotland it was evolved
hundreds and hundreds of years ago to
use up all the pieces of an animal
mainly lamb as in the langs the liver
the heart that you wouldn't normally use
in everyday cooking
traditionally harvest is encased in the
sheep's stomach
fun fact these days stomachs are not
really used anymore they're actually
being made in non-edible casings which
are easier to cook with and they don't
have a
let's just say distinctive odor
making haggis is no easy feat to make
haggis from the start from the raw
ingredients it takes roughly 18 to 20
hours
first we cook the hargis ingredients
overnight then we sort the meats out we
mince it all together with the dry
ingredients and then after that goes
into the filling machine
it is then put into the boilers for the
last and final cooking and it's served
any number of ways
traditionally like this with potatoes
and turnips but today chefs they're
getting more creative
[Music]
the flavor of harvest is quite unique it
tastes savoury very rich you can't eat
too much of it it's quite heavy as well
honestly we tried the haggis and it's
really good here anyway this secret
recipe fraser didn't actually make
himself the original recipe was
introduced into the shop by jockey
mccullum i worked with jockey for many
many years
i've now dabbled his number of years in
the shop so i think i can call it my
recipe now
to keep this
tradition going is it's quite hard in
this day and age with the cost of
everything but we've tried our best and
obviously we're gonna have to keep it
going and faster on the next generation
can we see the recipe
no
you can buy the shop and then i can show
[Music]
you in mississippi
and everywhere you go tamales
those magical little snacks of corn
flour and meat packed into a corn husk
tamales tamales tamales
so if you've ever wondered what
mississippi tastes like
it tastes like me
the tamale
[Music]
my journey starts almost 100 years ago
it's 1930
and mexican migrants are trickling into
mississippi
they bring along a taste of home their
version of the sandwich
me
the tamale
my great grandfather came here from
mexico city
jumped the trains ended up in
mississippi he decided to make his
family's homemade hand-rolled hot
tamales and in 1939 opened up this place
and started selling tamales
you have to understand this is a family
thing i'm the fourth generation
these same generational people who've
been coming to the big apple in for the
last 78 years are also generational when
they eat a tamale they always have a
story my daddy used to bring me here his
daddy had the same kind of story his
daddy had the same kind of story
tamales caught on here and it became a a
staple in in the city
so there i am winning over the
mississippi natives and as i make my way
up into the delta
my location may change but little did i
know that the tradition of family most
certainly would not
just like gino and his grandfather at
the big apple inn i bring the scott
family together a family who has gone on
to be known
as the first family of tamales in
mississippi
in the early 50s my father bought the
recipe from a mexican guy
my mother and father taught me
my sisters and my niece all of us
together we're making hot tamales we
just one big hot tamale family
any business that's family oriented
i think it'll last longer
[Music]
much like the scott family
the dough family is made up of a long
line of tamale makers
dough's eat place is a landmark
restaurant that helped propel me to
become the backbone of mississippi
cuisine i've become today
[Music]
my daddy started this restaurant in
1941 with my mother we've been here 76
years
mama had a
sister that was living here
and daddy had a couple of two or three
sisters that were living here so they
all came and rolled tamales
you know a lot of people asked ask us
you know how did tamales get prevalent
in the delta
it's been family you know the family's
been here all the time
as tamales made their way from mexican
culture to african-american communities
and on to mississippi's white population
there's one thing that remained a
constant
family
the most southern concept of all
[Music]
you